[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
sociétés
le rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter et débattre des sujets qui font
l'actualité
la vie reprend petit à petit son cours
depuis le 19 mai dernier mais toujours
des règles à respecter des jauges
progressive actuellement et impasses
sanitaires à mettre en place pour
certains événements à partir du 9 juin
prochain
alors quelle application dans les
yvelines on en parle avec nos invités
sophie primas bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice l'est républicain des yvelines
florence k - bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directrice du théâtre coluche de plaisir
et christophe graffeuil bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes directeur de la royal factory
salle de spectacle à versailles alors de
19 mai dernier le sénat a adopté
l'ensemble du projet de loi de sortie de
crise sanitaire par 221 voix contre 102
sophie primas vous avez même voté pour
vous même voté pour ce projet de loi
intègre notamment le pass année terre la
loi est paru au journal officiel le 1er
juin
les sénateurs ont précisé qu'ils ne
pourraient être mis en oeuvre que dans
les lieux ne permettant de ne permettant
pas pardon d'assurer le respect des
gestes barrières
pourquoi cette précision notamment vous
savez qu'au sénat on est très très
attachés aux libertés individuelles donc
il était d'abord pas question de rendre
ce bassin terre obligatoire mais nous
avons ensuite souhaité encadrer un
certain nombre de possibilités
d'utilisation pour sécuriser la liberté
individuelle dans les libertés
individuelles et est-ce que vous
mentionnez à l'instant il a aussi des
questions sur le stockage sur
l'utilisation des dorés donc ces mesures
de précaution est en prise il nous
sommes que pour redonner vie
à tous ceux qui a envie de renaître dans
le printemps la culture le théâtre les
spectacles événementiels les concerts et
toutes les grandes manifestations
il ya beaucoup de monde et bien il
fallait accepter ce pass sanitaires
alors se passe sanitaire justement ne va
concerner que les lieux et événements au
delà de 1000 personnes pour préparer
cette émission nous avons contacté des
sites qui de par leurs capacités
d'accueil sont concernés par ce passe
mais ils ont plutôt choisi de mettre en
place un protocole sanitaire et des
jauges plus basse nous avons aussi
demandé à nos téléspectateurs si le pass
sanitaire serait un frein pour se rendre
sur des événements c'est le nom qu'ils
l'emportent avec 53% des voix à nouveau
à vous sophie primas ce qu'il faut
encourager les professionnels aussi à
atteindre leurs capacités habituelles
or ben je pense qu'il y en a deux
professionnels ici pense que plus vite y
seront à leur jauge maximum vite y
serons heureux donc je pense que
l'encouragement il viendra au
probablement de même alors il ya des
difficultés peut-être dans
l'organisation des entrées à vérifier
une passe sanitaires à mettre en place
quelques quelques dispositions de
vérification qui s'est toujours à ça va
toujours été un peu probablement
compliquer et 6 voilà à l'entrée sont
mille dire non à quelqu'un qui n'a pas
le pass sanitaire donc ça c'est toujours
un truc un petit peu compliqué mais je
pense que l'intérêt des professionnels
qui ont beaucoup souffert en 2020
beaucoup souffert en cette année en ce
début d'année 2021 il me semble que leur
intérêt ça va être de retrouver vite les
jauges les plus importantes et si
l'intérêt des français parce qu'en
discutant tout à l'heure avec mancka
mois avant cette émission rapidement
voilà tout le monde a très envie d'aller
au cinéma 13 envie d'aller au tertre est
en partie dans les expositions et dans
les grands et dans les grands
rassemblements festifs
je pense que tout ça va se c'est un peu
comme le vaccin il y avait beaucoup
d'anti vaccin ou le budget des choses se
mettent en place
voilà tout le monde il adhère petit à
petit alors pour nous mon le pass n'est
pas encore en place puisque ce sera à
partir du 9 juin et florence k - vous au
théâtre
coluche vous n'êtes pas concernés par le
passage des terres de par sa capacité
d'accueil
parce que votre salle possède 8 168
places très exactement mais vous êtes
soumis comme tous lieux de spectacles à
une jauge de spectateurs aujourd'hui la
jauge est de 35% elle passera à 65% le 9
juin et la reprise c'est vous ce fait le
11 juin avec pixel une chorégraphie par
mourad merzouki pourquoi il n'avait pas
repris dès le 19 mai florence k moi
c'est que les productions ont préféré un
record ont tant mieux parce que c'était
de très gros ce spectacle est une jauge
à 35% soit un petit peu compliqué c'est
à dire qu'ils les places ont été vendues
garneau en juin quand on avoue vers les
abonnements employés déjà tous aller
tout allait pour le mieux mais
finalement non donc comment faire on va
pas rembourser la moitié des spectateurs
pour respecter la jauge donc on a
préféré reporter deux trois spectacles
qui était prévu avant le 9 juin
c'était vraiment d'un commun accord avec
les productions et voilà tout ce tracé
en très bonne accor et le rangement donc
nous accueillons pixels de mourad
merzouki avec une jauge à 65% du coup ça
représente à peu près pour notre grande
salle qui a la chance d'être grande mais
inférieur à 8 places
ça représente 170 spectateurs exactement
j'ai fait le calcul
et voilà et on va avoir beaucoup de
jeunes on va voir le collège blaise
pascal
d'une surface de 4 va venir en nombre
avec ses élèves suite à vos projets pour
mener avec le département et là les les
dernières places en france de se vendre
à toute vitesse
vous allez arriver aux 100 % des 65 % ou
de vous même vous vous mettez une
barrière un peu mon talent n'ont de
toute façon d
ce rappel 570 dans ses 570 aussi les
invités et nourrissent pour ce spectacle
un spectacle très technique très très
beau visuellement on a une région salle
donc voilà je pense que ça va bien se
répartir au niveau des spectateurs
est-ce que je tenais à dire aussi par
rapport à toutes les mesures que nous
avons mis en place grâce à notre très
grand lieu qui est très sécure c'est que
nous avons une entrée par le haut une
entrée par le bas et on commence à faire
en sorte que les gens ne se fasse pas
dès l'entrée c'est à dire que les
spectateurs vous montrer par le haut et
on les fera sortir par le bas on leur
fait s'imbiber les mains de gilles gel
hydroalcoolique
dès l'entrée le port du masque pour leur
dis tout le temps tout trajet les
obligatoires on a renforcé l'équipe
d'accueil les hôtes et hôtesses
d'accueil les personnes au contrôle
sécurité et il accompagne chaque groupe
de spectateurs jusqu'à leur siège
on a demandé au public d'être un peu
conciliant c'est à dire que dans notre
salle le public est placé
sauf que là on ne peut plus garantir la
place on ne peut plus garantir que le
roi et on commence à placer les
spectateurs plus pro les premiers
arrivés par le milieu et on étire vers
le bord ce qui fit que les gens ne se
pose même pas dans les années et on est
je leur fais un discours au début en
leur expliquant que pour la sortie on
commencera par le rang du bas que ils
doivent rester à distance d'un mètre des
uns des autres
on a même eu la situation certains
bonhommes parce qu'on avait déjà mis
tout ça en place de ventes de produits
dérivés à la sortie la première fois les
gens commençait à s'amasser près des
produits on leur a dit non attendez et
approchez vous des artistes chacun à
votre tour vraiment ont mis tout en
oeuvre pour que ça aille bien et
franchement en septembre/octobre camp
avant que le conçoit reconfirmer on a eu
strictement
testé un petit peu le respect de tous
les gestes franchement aucun souci et en
plus nous on a la chance d'avoir le nom
l'adresse le téléphone de tout le monde
donc la petite liste qu'on demande aux
rays d'horreur de fer d'office ou moins
si un spectateur
moi j'ai une fois une dame qui peuplent
mais après vous êtes sûre capable de 4go
vide
je lui ai dit non mais si vous en avez
si jamais vous avez attrapé qu'ovide
appelez-moi est enfin nécessaire auprès
des spectateurs qui étaient autour de
vous on n'en sait donc comment ça se
passe du côté de versailles jusqu'à la
royale factory le 19 mai a été comme un
soulagement j'imagine et vous avez
repris dès le 21 mai la joueuse de 35%
christophe graffeuil ça vous a pas
empêché de rouvrir ça n'a pas été un
obstacle
non vraiment on n'a pas loupé l'occasion
en fait des données et c'était important
de trouver preneur pour les artistes au
public pour nous parce que enfin au
travail et enfin on n'est plus
considérée comme un lieu de
contamination parce que ça a été ça
pendant dix mois
on est des lieux de contamination est
aujourd'hui s'est terminée jeudi
il va y avoir un travail important à
faire de la part de l'état de dire que
c'est pas des lieux de contamination ça
c'est vraiment le plus important
aujourd'hui pour retrouver un public qui
n'a pas la crainte de venir voir du
spectacle vivant et je crois franchement
que c'est là dessus que ça va jouer
parce qu'aujourd'hui on joue sur votre
public qui fit d'elle il est venu
c'était complet à 100% sur les haies sur
les 35 % de jeu 35 % mais on est content
ça fait déjà cinq représentations
complètes
là on à victor hugo je dis ça sera
complet aussi aux molière on est content
mais vraiment on a besoin d'une
communication importante des
collectivités territoriales de l'état du
ministère la culture parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans la tête des gens on
est toujours des lieux de contamination
et ça ça fait très très mal
oui sophie primas justement il faut
réinstaurer presque un lien de confiance
est ce que en tant que président de la
commission des affaires économiques vous
êtes attentive aussi à la reprise de ces
secteurs
oui bien sûr parce que ce sont des
secteurs culturels sont aussi des
secteurs économiques qui en voit
beaucoup de monde et
qui en plus d'avoir un lien et un rôle
social du rail dans la société sont
vraiment des entreprises à part entière
donc je souscris complètement à ce que
vous visez monsieur sur le fait d'avoir
un peu trop mis l'accent sur le fait que
des salles de spectacles de cinéma
étaient des zones de contamination on
voit bien quand madame k - nous explique
toutes les précautions tous les
protocoles qui ont été mis en place dans
le théâtre
coluche et évidemment il n'y a pas de
contamination dans ces conditions là on
est on respecte distance pas vous prenez
tout tout tout toutes les précautions
nécessaires sa demande d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'investissements parce que je
vous entends à dire que vous oubliez
outre et pilier de vente de personnes
qui accompagnent les gens donc oui je
suis parfaitement d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut bien mettre dans la tête des
gens mais je pense que l' envie va va
être au dessus de la crac voilà mais
vous savez on a le même sujet sur mais
les bureaux de vote pour la fin du mois
de juin
c'est un peu la même chose puisque la
haye de la contamination a explosé après
le deuxième tour des élections
municipales en 2010 bien ça c'est resté
dans la tête des gens donc on est un peu
là là même la même problématique avec
évidemment des enjeux qui sont là
démocratique mais pour vous culturels et
sociétaux qui sont très importants et
économique
louis christian graffeuil vous comment
ça se passe à la royale factory madame k
- nous a expliqué tout ce qui est mis en
place
vous avez ou la possibilité de faire une
entrée et une sortie de modifier un
petit peu votre fonctionnement interne
le fonctionnement il reste le même je
dirais que tout était mis en place le
protocole il a été pensé réfléchi et
franchement on met les misions barrières
tout va bien on a incité à saisir un
centre de traitement d'air avec un
renouvellement total de l'air parce que
c'était un moment le point crucial est
importante pour ces lieux clos et nous
c'est le cas comme tout l'été je pense
que l'espace coluche à la même chose
c'était à et franchement le centre de
traitement d'air on est considéré comme
un avion ou un train se dire c'est la
même chose donc à partir de là il ya
zéro risque sur l'air qui voit ses
arômes helmand à 100% la salle est
continuellement en la représentation
florence k - vous avez vous aussi
le renouvellement de l'air automatique
jeux wii où on a tout ce qu'il faut de
ce point de vue là qu'ils sont nés y ont
tellement grande salle vous avez montré
des photos tout à l'heure avec une très
grosse hauteur de plafond
donc non il a de ce point de vue là il
n'y a strictement aucun problème de
notre côté oui je voulais rajouter que
moi j'ai pas du tout le sentiment que
les gens et la moindre crainte de
revenir au théâtre
je pense qu'ils sont totalement
confiance et en plus ils nous écoutent
mais de façon vraiment religieuse quand
on leur dit là où ils doivent s'asseoir
et hyper compréhensif d'un bout à
l'autre de leur trajet dans le iv il
porte le masque
vraiment je n'ai jamais vu personne
investie son masque sur une île et que
ça passe et moi je non non ça je ne
savais pas peur du tout la crainte du
public
le coc vide dans un théâtre christophe
graphique vous vouliez réagir nous le
pourrons molière au un versailles ca -
très important pour nous on a pu on a pu
bouger un petit peu ce qui se passe en
termes de réservations ont fait à peu
près trois représentations par semaine
on sent que c'est vous quand même on a
nos plus fidèles qui vient effectivement
qui est venu sur les cinq
représentations ce qui est complet on a
quand même une formation qui était
jusqu'au mois de juillet et on sent
quand même sur les spectacles qui sont
vraiment super parce qu'on est outre de
réfléchir la programmation il est
vraiment attirante
c'est quand même un peu mou et pour la
rentrée parce qu on est déjà sur la
rentrée on voit bien que les têtes
d'affiché comme laura l'onu elodie poo
s'émousser un peu mou donc on va bien
voir mais je dirais qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un court travail de communication de la
part de l'état je pense que c'est
indispensable mais vraiment y aller très
fort ce soir l'un des collectivités
territoriales nous on en a besoin parce
que on n'a pas daté n'a pas d'adhérents
je dirais donc dans une salle privée
on joue que sur notre public et je
dirais qu un public fidèle vient à peu
près 3 4 fois dans moi mais un public
qui vient de temps en temps au théâtre
des fois c'est leur première rentrée au
théâtre aux as et parlez vous
et ils viennent quoi deux fois une fois
dans l'année et c'est celui ci ce public
là qu'on n'a pas là pas trouvés
donc oui aujourd'hui trouver un nouveau
public ça va être super important sophie
primas finalement est-ce que alesi
belles choses en plus je voulais un peu
un peu réagir là où je vous comprends
parfaitement monsieur sait que dans le
brouhaha de communication sur ce qui est
interdit ce qui est pas interdite avec
le pass sanitaire avec 1000 places avec
500 places avec des jauges jusqu'aux
oeuvres jusqu'au ont jusqu'au 25
jusqu'au fin juin très clairement je
pense que les français sont complètement
perdus donc je pense et moi je crois
beaucoup à la communication de proximité
donc je pense à la fois à votre
structure des sourds au théâtre comique
mais que votre structure doit
communiquer que la collectivité
territoriale doit vous accompagner et
que c'est comme ça que ça se passera
parce que honnêtement la communication
du gouvernement et c'est pas tellement
de critiques parce que c'est pas si
facile que ça mais la convocation est
tellement confuse sur tous les sujets
sur les restaurants sont l'ouverture le
couvre-feu pas le couvre-feu à quelle
heure les jo je le passais anitea
riksdag
tout ça est très très confus quand on
n'est pas dedans et du coup je souhaite
en effet si vos réservations peuvent
être un peu molle c'est parce que les
gens se disent heureux là est ce que
finalement on a le droit d'y aller je
pense qu'il faut se faire sa propre
communication avec les collectivités à
auteuil
et puis l'été arrive on a aussi envie
d'être dehors sauf si moi je voudrais
rester avec vous ce que l'été c'est
plutôt propice aux festivals et aux
animations extérieures comment est-ce
qu'on peut garantir la sécurité
sanitaire sans diminuer l'identité d'un
rendez vous quelles seraient les
préconisations au niveau du sénat pour
qu'on garde cette identité d'un festival
notamment
alors je suis désolé mais via une
coupure de connexion je n'ai pas entendu
votre question désolé je voulais savoir
si l'été étant propice au festival à
arras animations extérieures quand
est-ce qu'on peut garantir la sécurité
ce que finalement dans un spectacle
extérieur on est assis on sait qu'on
peut pas bouger on est dans le noir
il ya peut-être pas ce même rendez vous
ce même sentiment sur un festival sur un
festival
l'objectif c'est quand même de bouger
éventuellement voix ne s'est pas assis
danse et de sa troupe et de vivre
quelque chose d'un peu collectif donc
c'est effectivement plutôt propice à une
petite amie nation par la proximité des
personnes alors s'il vous plaît nerfs
d'opéra ou de choses comme ça où les
gens sont assis c'est un petit peu
différent naturellement mais les
festivals je pas les vieilles charrues
ou des choses comme ça bon ça on est
déjà à côté des autres quand on a une
jauge de très importantes là je pense
que le pass annie terre peut être peut
être une réponse à cette à ces
difficultés auxquelles à qui pour le
coup est une vraie difficulté même si
c'est en plein air voilà on a tous été
dans les festivals on sait à quel point
la proximité voilà est importante
il ya des moments aussi sur lesquels il
faut faire un peu une croit encore à la
royale factory que les stands graffeuil
avant les spectacles il y avait ces
petits moments de repas vous ne les fait
plus j'imagine que vous avez hâte aussi
d'y revenir
ça fait partie des atouts c'est vrai que
c'est important pour nous le jeu de
d'ouvrir un petit verre parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un petit café théâtre
on est un peu comme un communiq loeb un
petit peu plus en plus ailleurs à paris
avec des petits débris dont des petites
tables et les gens apprécient bien de
boire un verre juste avant spectacle on
ne fait pas pendant mais juste avant
spectacle en ont une
ils viennent se détendre pour une petite
assiette voir attisé et ça je crois
qu'ils apprécient beaucoup c'est un tout
c'est l'artiste qui est bon c'est le
lieu qui est sympathique et puis ce
petit zahia qui permet juste avant le
théâtre de passer une très bonne soirée
et florence k mois est ce qu'on change
aussi la communication auprès des
spectateurs qui finit sur tout mais vous
avez parfaitement raison nous parle
artistique
bon alors on leur dit qu'à partir du 9
juin
le couvre-feu pas ça devrait passer à 23
heures parce que bon il faut rester
prudent sur les propos mais notre rôle
n'est pas forcément de communiquer sur
les mesures gouvernementales notre rôle
c'est parler d' artistique de garantir
aux gens qu'ils seront en sécurité chez
nous et qu'on respecte les règles
chacun chacun sa place bros et c'est
important de le dire
voilà si on nous avait dit qu'il fallait
un pass sanitaire ça nous aurait un
petit peu quand même en péter parce
qu'imaginez que depuis les attentats du
bataclan des gens fouillent les gens
maintenant leur demande de mettre du gel
hydroalcoolique
c'est tout à insérer un circuit alors si
en plus ils doivent montrer un pass pour
sanitaires ça aurait été vraiment
vraiment compliqué on en compte mais
bien sûr on s'adapte mais où le théâtre
c'est un lieu de convivialité avant tout
les gens sont là pour surtout se
retrouver en l'air les personnes d'une
même ville ne se retrouve pas vraiment
c'est compliqué on veut faire des
expositions si dans notre rôle c'est
c'est il faut créer une circulation pour
que les gens puissent en profiter enfin
il ya plein de l'animation qu'on fait
aussi autour des spectacles on a un peu
plein de choses le baril est fermé
depuis un an
ça ne sert manque aux spectateurs toutes
ces petites choses qui font la soirée au
théâtre on essaye de les préserver mais
ça va venir petit à petit sophie primas
finalement se passe à lutter c'est
georges c'est aussi une manière peut
être de dire il faut encore patienter
pour retrouver une vie d'avant
je pense que personne n'a envie en
septembre prochain de se re confiné
voilà je pense clairement qu'il a des
risques que la vaccination est pas
encore tout à fait là où elle devrait
être
pour immuniser totalement la population
donc je pense pas plus les français
voilà deux professionnels de la culture
la vie contre confinement fin septembre
ou au début du mois d'octobre
donc oui il faut encore faire attention
oui il faut porter le masque dans les
endroits où il ya la proximité discuter
oui il faut faire fossé avait les mains
un pour mettre du gel
bon même quand on est vacciné parait-il
et puis il faut se faire vacciner et
puis voilà la vie reprendra il faut
faire des efforts où est donc encore un
petit peu monsieur le bourreau voilà
pourquoi on retrouve notre liberté
la vie reprendra christian graffeuil la
saison prochaine elle est prête à la
royale on a eu tout le temps de la
préparer non c'est vrai on est prêts on
est prêt à accueillir public
ça va être très important pour nous on
peut me le disent et la sénatrice de
voilà de communiquer à tous les niveaux
parce que c'est ça qui va être vraiment
moteur ça fait vraiment très mal de
savoir que pendant plus d'un an on était
une contamination ça faut bien se le
dire c'était terrible ont été considérés
comme d'habitude formation aujourd'hui
c'est terminé et c'est il faut le dire
c'est super important et vous florence k
- septembre 2021
le tec et après présentation de saison
aura lieu le vendredi 3 septembre à
20h30
on a reporté une vingtaine de spectacles
de la saison passée certains n'ont pas
pu être reconduit pour x raison et on a
une quinzaine de très très beaux
spectacles des spectacles auxquels je
tiens absolument que ce sera vraiment la
seule occasion de les voir sur cette
saison là et j'ai l'impression que du
coup mon projet de programmation s'est
bonifié ça sera encore plus beau donc là
je suis là pour maintenant pour séduire
les gens pour qu'ils sachent que ce que
j'ai choisi pour eux c'est vraiment de
un fort désir des spectacles que j'ai vu
il voit là je les attends nombreux parce
que je suis là pour leur faire passer de
merveilleuses soirée madame primat est
ce que vous voulez conclure non jeu
jusqu'au ça donne envie je n'ai
peut-être pas avoir d assez de soirée
libre pour aller dans les deux dans les
deux salles mais en tout cas ça donne
envie depuis toute façon on a envie de
voir de retrouver ces moments de culture
et de convivialité
même si on doit faire un petit peu
attention donc je pense qu'il faut être
raisonnable il faut être sérieux faut se
faire vacciner si on veut aller dans les
festivals danser avec les autres et ben
en fait sont pas sanitaires on se
vaccine mauvais sens pas sanitaires et
puis on retrouve le cours normal de la
vie on a tous besoin voilà en tout cas
merci à wall voilà ces deux à ces deux
professionnels de la culture qu'ils sont
tout deux eu des bons alors il
semblerait qu'on ait perdu la connexion
avec madame prima donc je vous prends
parce qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots merci
de nous avoir suivi le statut de société
maintenant terminée on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau moment
de discussion et d'ici là prenez soin de
vous
il
[Musique]